bonjour à tous et leur de parlement
hebdo 45 minutes pour refaire la tue
politique et parlementaire de la semaine
avec michael annett au locataire
bonjour michael et c'était une semaine
sous haute tension marquée par la
polémique sur le drame de siemens les
réactions politiques se sont enchaînées
après la mort d'un jeune manifestant sur
le lieux du barrage contesté attaqué
notamment par les verts l'exécutif a
appelé au calme le conseil général du
tarn a suspendu la construction du
barrage une enquête est en cours
le gouvernement a décidé de résilier le
contrat passé avec et comme vous vous
connaissez cette société chargée de la
mise en place de la collecte de
l'écotaxe combien cela va coûter qui va
payer
pour l'instant c'est encore un peu flou
et puis c'est voter les sénateurs ont
adopté une carte de france à 15 régions
une alsace indépendante et pas de fusion
entre languedoc-roussillon et
midi-pyrénées
contre l'avis du gouvernement qui défend
une carte à 13 régions
notre invité cette semaine emmanuel
coste bonjour vous êtes secrétaire
nationale d'europe écologie les verts
alors c'est une tradition dans cette
émission le portrait est dressé par deux
parlementaires je vous propose de
l'écouter on réagit bien sûr juste après
je crois qu'elle a une parole qui est
une parole le courageuse
elle est réactive par rapport par
rapport aux problèmes d'actualité et je
sais que elle a le souci de développer
des dialogues avec les autres forces de
gauche
je la vois un peu comme une
ayatollahs verts elle est quand même
pour beaucoup de ses positions très
tranchées parfois excessives
emmanuel coste moi je dirais que c'est
une femme qui marient parfaitement
l'engagement militant anciens pour elle
bien avant de lier d'être engagé dans un
parti politique et l'exercice des
responsabilités comme donne sentiments
ce n'est pas forcément une critique de
ma part plus comme une militante qu'une
responsable politique peut-être le
dernier et les morceaux d'or qu'on vient
d'entendre militants tous que chef de
parti que j'avais du mal encore à
trouver le costume non mais moi je cache
pas que je suis très engagé depuis l'âge
de 18 ans est essentiellement j'étais
très engagé dans la lutte contre le sida
j'étais président d'une grande
association qui s'appelle act up j'ai
beaucoup travaillé sur la question de
précarité de défense des sans papiers
donc ça c'est ma vie et j'ai aussi voulu
la poursuivre à un moment dans un parti
et pour moi c'est une continuité ça va
de pair en tout cas pour moi je me
fatigue c'est pas incompatible est en
tout cas un moment j'avais aussi envie
vous je voulais et faire évoluer aussi
mon engagement ayatollahs verte sur
daniel fasquelle c'est vous ça oui non
c'est pas moi c'est pas vraiment
merveilleux mais en plus si vous voulez
la caricature qu'on parle des écolos
d'utiliser des mots comme ayatollahs aux
khmers déjà par rapport à l'histoire
mondiale et notamment à ce qui a été
déplacé je pense que c'est très déplacé
très souvent mais oui parce que j'ai à
19h leurs attendus cette semaine aussi
sur les polémiques on va y venir
mais ce sont des mots three forks
octobre prochain les verts aujourd'hui
complètement stupide et stupide
outrancier et moi je pense que les gens
qui ont une telle outrance quand ils
parlent d'autres gens dans la société ou
une vision aussi très binaire de la
société et je crois que voilà il faut
cette violence qui s'exprime à notre
égard que des gens soient pas d'accord
et où c'est une chose c'est ce qui s'est
fait pour vous pour votre parti oui et
parce que je pense que ce que nous
disons dérangeant dérange et ça va au
delà du clivage gauche droite c'est que
quand on remet en cause une vision très
productiviste par exemple de projet nous
dérangeons aussi quelque chose qu'un
celle d'une société depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale
la semaine commence avec le drame de
stevens qui a déclenché beaucoup de
violentes réactions politiques
stephens dans le tarn 26 octobre un
jeune homme de 21 ans aurélie frais et
tuées lors de violents affrontements
avec les forces de l'ordre sur le site
du barrage contesté à paris l'exécutif
attend 48 heures avant d'exprimer sa
compassion déclenchant une violente
polémique caroline motte
l'exécutif est sorti de son silence
trois jours après la mort de rémy
fraysse lors d'une violente
manifestation contre le projet de
barrage sivens françois hollande s'est
exprimé mes mots sont ceux d'abord
adressé à la famille la compassion la
solidarité mais qu'est ce qui s'est
produit
la vérité doit être connu et enfin il y
a une responsabilité que chacun doit
avoir dans son expression dans
l'hémicycle manuel valls a réagi aux
propos de cécile duflot un peu plus tôt
la députée très en colère dénonçaient
une tache indélébile sur l'action du
gouvernement fasse un tel drame
chacun doit faire preuve de
responsabilité mais aussi de dignité
c'est la seule attitude possible quand
on est un responsable politique quand on
est un élu
on ne peut pas faire de déclarations à
l'emporte-pièce on ne peut pas désigner
des responsables alors même que la
justice n'a pas terminé son travail il
faut que justice soit faite que la
vérité
soit donnée non seulement à ses proches
à sa famille mais aux français
certains écologistes se veulent plus
offensif et met en cause la
responsabilité du gouvernement
moi j'appelle à la responsabilité de
monsieur hollande et de monsieur valls
est la seule responsabilité qui doit
être la leur aujourd'hui c'est d'annuler
la déclaration d'utilité publique
on ne construit pas un barrage sur un
cadavre lors d'une conférence de presse
le procureur d'albi s'est exprimé la
thèse d'une grenade offensive lancée par
les gendarmes est privilégiée alors
voilà le conseil général du tarn a
suspendu la poursuite de la construction
de ce barrage vous dit aux manifestants
de quitter les lieux du barrage
vous l'avez déjà ce que nous disons
c'est qu'il faut arrêter ce barrage est
pas le support mais je pense que ce
matin le conseil général en décidant de
suspendre veut pas en fait regarder le
dossier dans son entièreté y compris et
on veut puisque enfin tout le monde
s'intéresse à ce barrage donc on peut
redire des arguments tout développement
plusieurs mois c'est que les études
d'impact qui ont amené le vote des élus
du conseil général de temps pour
soutenir le projet en fait ont été
faites à fort longtemps sur des données
qui ne sont pas bonnes et les experts
ont bien dit qu'en fait ce barrage ne se
justifiait pas vous allez le dire
ce barrage aujourd'hui la construction
les suspendus j'ai pas passée je
prendrai la résidence qui doit s'arrêter
et pourquoi parce que dans le rapport
d'expertisé indépendant qui a été donc
rendu après que nous l'ayons demandé
parce que c'était quand même fou que sur
un dossier où il ya une confrontation
depuis des mois qu'il soit impossible
d'avoir une expertise indépendante parce
que les délais d p a été faite sur des
rapports de 2001 il faut quand même un
peu regardé le dossier dans sa globalité
ce que dit ce rapport aussi c'est qu'on
peut faire autrement il ya un problème
d'eau dans le tarn
c'est une évidence il ya un problème
d'eau pour les agriculteurs aussi entre
tout le monde il y avait un accord entre
ge et vous dire comment ça se passe dans
ce cas là il y avait un accord entre un
président du cg qui dit c'est ma
solution s'accoutume millions d'euros et
c'est comme ça et vous allez être
d'accord selon mes arguments et
justement ce que font les écologistes
dans beaucoup de ces projets c'est
qu'ils discutent de tout est ce que
vraiment on doit supprimer une zone
humide car un envie
un effet sur la qualité de
l'environnement dans cette zone
est ce qu'on doit la supprimer pour 8
millions d'euros est ce qu'on peut faire
autrement mais une discussion pour vous
c'est rocard ou non la contestation a
commencé à monter très fortement et pas
qu'avec des jeunes qui s'impose dans le
tarn ya aussi localement des gens et
compris des agriculteurs qui sont
opposés à ce barrage depuis un moment
nous avions dit monsieur carcenac rock
rencontrer les fêtes une discussion
travail au consensus
est ce que c'est ce barrage qu'il faut
faire et ce qu'on peut pas faire des
revenus dont elle a été forcée par cinq
et une telle confrontation
il faut qu'elle a autant monter mais
elles montrent aussi pas seulement dans
le tarn à rennes il ya eu de violentes
échauffourées
je pense que je me trompe pas mélanger
deux choses appelé au calme sur souffel
très clairement et autant plus je ne
fais que ça depuis une semaine
d'une part la famille de rémy fraysse et
je pense là là là
ce qu'était rémy fraises ce qu'on nous
dit c'est vraiment très éloigné de ces
manifestations de violence
la famille derby face ne veut pas du
tout ces manifestations la part de
rentrées chez elles et surtout de ne pas
manifester s'ils ont des choses moi
aussi je suis très en colère la mort de
ce jeune homme et moi je vais vous dire
je vais pas manifestés en allant casser
quoi que ce soit on exprime simplement
sur cette colère là et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui tous les gens qui
utilisent la violence pour manifester
là-dessus font des erreurs et c'est pour
ça qu'à gagner la suspension aujourd'hui
de ce projet elle a lieu parce qu'il ya
eu des violences
alors écoutez moi samedi avant qu'ils
aient la mort de rémy fraysse il se
trouve que partout notamment parce que
la spl reçoit le rapport d expertise
arrive dans les rédactions et d'un seul
coup alors depuis huit mois y compris
manuel valls dit on va tenir bon ce
barrage il est formidable et c'est vous
avez d'un seul coup un regard critique
sur ce barrage est déjà le projet
vaciller fortement et moi je vais vous
le dire c'est pas à cause de la violence
qu'il faut arrêter ce barrage c'est
parce que il est inutile il faut
répondre autrement aux besoins des
agriculteurs dans le coin on peut faire
des retenues d'eau on n'est pas obligé
de dépenser 8 millions d'euros
et en plus et ça c'est un autre problème
pour monsieur carcenac sait qu'il n'a
pas le financement de ce barrage moi
j'aimerais savoir comment ils payent
comment ils payent y compris ce qu'il a
déjà entrepris parce que ce n'est pas
financé qu'est ce que vous leur dites
aux manifestants aujourd'hui qui sont
sur le barrage s'arrête
il arrête tout ils partent non moi je
pense que j'ai pas à alourdir des
chaussures de militants écologistes
l'étang écologistes il y en a d'autres
et il ya plein d'organisation qui sont
investis localement
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui la nécessité
c'est qu'on recrée la zone humide au
plus vite
je vous avais soit près de 10 mais c'est
pas qu'ils rentrent chez eux ils font ce
qu'ils veulent de leur vie et j'ai pas
leur donner des consignes à tous les
combats moi je pense en tout cas que
tant que ce barrage n'est pas arrêtée il
faut continuer la mobilisation et la
mobilisation elle a lieu sur un plan
juridique sur un plan média doit avoir
lieu localement sur place dans des
formes pacifique il faut être très clair
mais derrière vous regardez les
manifestants moi même je n'en ai pas
rencontrés mais j'ai beaucoup discutent
les élus locaux et écologistes qui les
ont beaucoup rencontrer ces gens depuis
des semaines vous avez des gens très
violents qui se sont exprimé samedi mais
la majorité des gens qui sont là sont
vraiment dans une autre histoire
politique est très éloigné de ses
pratiques violentes c'est plutôt des
gens qui sont objectivement amoureux de
la nature et qui sont dans une relation
à la nature qui est très différente des
jeunes hommes qu'on a vu que ce qui fait
passer décribilise un peu votre parti
parce que vous êtes attaché quelque part
à l'image de ce qui s'est passé
non je ne crains pas du tout
objectivement non je fins et très loin
de moi je vais vous dire pourquoi
d'une part pour nous cette saison sur le
barrage de sivens elle n'est pas
nouvelle
ça fait des mois et même des années pour
les élus des plus au fait de sujets
qu'on est dessus et c'est les élus et
d'europe écologie les verts et fait-il
duflot la première ou noël mamère qu'on
a perdus dans le reportage qui montent
au front le qg de plus de façons la
première que monter au front c'est moi
même et josé bové pour dire un truc et
je pense que c'est lié aussi à notre
histoire politique et vous ne regrettez
pas certains mots qui sont les je ne
regrette rien vous savez ce que je
regrette je veux dire c'est que je n'ai
pas été assez dur avant la manifestation
de samedi pour empêcher ça je vais vous
le dire très franchement j'en ai parlé
avec josé bové noël nous avons fait
beaucoup de manifestations dans nos vies
et ce qui s'est passé samedi pour nous
la chose la plus terrible qui puisse se
passer on a tous fait des alertes aux
pouvoirs publics pour leur dire il ya de
la violence il faut il faut réfléchir
vraiment à comment ça se passe sur place
et moi mon regret je vais vous dire
c'est parce que j'ai fait après c'est
peut-être de ne pas voir encore plus
alerté les pouvoirs publics pour que
justement on n'anticipe pas encore plus
ce qui s'est passé que je vous propose
d'écouter peut-être le ministre de la
bernard cazeneuve qui a été accusé d'un
manque d'empathie écoutez sa réponse
était dans l'hémicycle au sénat on m'a
reproché encore ce matin de manquer de
coeur et ne pas avoir de compassion je
suis devant la représentation nationale
et je veux sur ces sujets m'exprimer en
sincérité j'ai au cours des dernières
années a eu à connaître des drames dans
ma propre circonscription et lorsqu'un
événement de ce type se produit que vous
êtes ministre de l'intérieur vous
interrogez votre conscience et les
choses au plus profond de vous même vous
essayez de trouver les mots justes et
vous les adresser à ceux auxquels vous
le devez les adresser avec pudeur
voilà ce que j'ai essayé de faire voilà
comme je manque comment j'essaie de me
comporter face à cette épreuve pour la
famille de rémy fraises qui est aussi je
vais vous le dire
une épreuve pour moi et je regrette que
certains profitent de cet événement non
pas pour que la vérité l'emportent mais
pour faire de la politique en abaissant
tout dans votre corps les mots étaient
très dures contre bernard cazeneuve
qu'est ce que vous lui reprochez au min
de l'intérieur moi j'ai un reproche
global qui est que je regarde la
chronologie des faits dimanche matin
nous apprenons qu'un corps est retrouvé
dans la forêt un corps est retrouvé dans
la forêt la réalité c'est que les forces
de police savait déjà que c'était un
jeune qui avait été tuée par une grenade
parce que il le voit au niveau du corps
tout simplement
la famille halliday heures à savoir que
c'était leur fils nous n'avons après
nous que le soir qu'il était et pendant
deux jours aucune parole publique
quelles que soient les circonstances de
la mort quand vous êtes ministre de
l'intérieur qu'il y avait un mort dans
une manifestation qui a été déclaré vous
devez dire que c'est un bras c'est une
faute politique pour vous je ne sais pas
je sais très compliqué parce que oui il
ya quelque chose en tout cas qui cloche
totalement il me semble je veux pas voir
des qualificatifs extrêmement actif je
pense qu'on a dit très clairement à
monsieur cazeneuve ce que nous pensions
c'est franchement oui très franchement
mais pourquoi parce qu'il ya un moment
quand le lundi moi j'ai les échos de la
famille on est en train de
d pour ceux conçus partie civile pour
essayer d'apaiser les choses que vous
n'entendez sur les chaînes d'info que le
fait que ce manifestant
s'il est peut-être mort parce qu'il
avait des grenades dans son sac à dos et
que peut-être été très violent vous
comprenez il ya une sorte de distance
complètement folle comment ça se fait
que dès le matin le mélies de
l'intérieur ne dis pas simplement il
s'est passé un drame
c'est un drame qu'un jeune homme soit
morts dans une manifestation au demande
pas plus au monde c'est pas compliqué
c'est quand même le minimum de dire
simplement c'est un drame et de ne pas
attendre que acculé par les écologistes
sur l'humour de papeete
c'est pas le sujet moi je vais vous dire
ce team en sorte aujourd'hui je sais
mais pour moi ce n'est pas le cas et
pour moi l'essentiel pour la suite c'est
que il l'a fait après aussi deux jours
il a fallu deux jours pour qu'ils le
disent que des enquêtes exemplaires soit
mené et je ne les attendons des enquêtes
administrative quel est le chaîne de
commandement est ce que lui l'islate
option j'attends son silence ou devrait
y avoir et aussi que la famille ne
vivent pas le calvaire que les temps de
famille quand il ya ces histoires là
c'est à dire des enquêtes qui durent des
années des procès qui n'ont pas lieu
vous savez la famille on est vendredi
leur enfant est mort samedi dans la
seine dimanche ils n'ont toujours pas
récupéré le corps de leur enfant il faut
vous ce que juste que vous comprenez
qu'elle est le traumatisme pour cesser
ces personnes qui doivent entendre
parler de leur fils partout qui n'ont
même pas pu encore voir le corps de leur
fils ne savent pas quoi et quand il va
être enterré
et c'est vrai que attendre 48 heures
pour que le gouvernement le président de
la république et ce mot de compassion
envers en plus une famille dont le père
est militant politique
sincèrement oui je ne regrette rien de
la virulence avec laquelle j'ai appelé à
ce qu'ils avancent message bien compris
l' enquête est en cours et nous on passe
à mardi avec une mesure très contestée
adopté à l'assemblée
et la modulation des allocations
familiales a donc été votée dans le
cadre du budget de la sécu pour 2015 34
députés socialistes se sont abstenus
cinq de moins que lors du vote du budget
les députés verts se sont abstenus une
fois de plus il ne doit plus ni le
budget ni celui de la sécu vous soutenez
toujours la majorité le gouvernement
oui mais on ne soutient pas ses choix
que j'étais un an mais c'est pas c'est
pas une blague et ça commence à devenir
un peu étrange c'est pas systématique
depuis mai 2012
il ya eu quelques votes et il y en a eu
à 3 ans chez qui elle a confiance et les
votes sur le bichon important c'est le
fait que c'est quand même le messager
sont importants mais c'est aussi pour ça
qu'on y travaille beaucoup et qu'on a
essayé aussi de dialoguer beaucoup avec
le gouvernement qu'on a aussi noté
compris dans le plfss des avancées
importantes
jean louis roumégas ce qui faisait les
explications de vote l'a redit la
suppression des franchises médicales
pour les personnes avancent c'est une
avancée surtout que ça faisait partie y
compris des conflits conte avec marisol
touraine dès mai 2012 où il y avait une
forte demande de malades pour les
personnels
parce que dans la globalité du budget le
compte n'y est pas et c'est pas les
mesures les mesures les unes après les
autres c'est qu'il y à une présentation
du budget global le rythme des économies
les choix qui sont faits le fait qu'on
fait tout porter sur les ménages est pas
une partie sur les entreprises nous
sommes ne pas aller ne pas aller dans le
sens où on veut aller et en même temps
vous voyez bien c'est une abstention ce
n'est pas des votes contre
le groupe écologiste ne veut pas rentrer
là dedans tu ne serais pas du tout mais
c'est aussi parce qu'il ya des députés
qui avant voté contre le budget et vous
avez remarqué que maintenant ils se sont
rangés à l'idée qu'il fallait mieux
s'abstenir de manière regroupée et avoir
un discours plus rassembleur sur et
conclut une abstention après la réalité
c'est que le gouvernement il travaille
comme les écologistes parce qu'il n'a
pas beaucoup d'alliés aujourd'hui il
faut quand même le dire aussi
on a vu le bras de fer avec le prg on
voit quand même que sur beaucoup de lois
les écologistes sont là aussi pour
amener une certaine identité aux lois et
je pense notamment travail qu'on a fait
sur la transition énergétique où on a
été des partenaires plus que loyaux et
surtout plus que présent pour que cette
loi voit le jour et qu'elle arrive
au bout vous avez encore des discussions
avec manuel valls j'en ai souvent avec
son cabinet bain salle avantage avec
manuel valls et que lui et moi pouvons
pour pratiquer une franchise formé y
compris avec le président de la
république on se dit les choses je crois
qu'il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de jeu
de départ n'ont pris la ferme si vannes
doit pas marquer une rupture dans vos
relations avec les caisses qui est
certes un excellent ballon ça jean
vincent placé qui a utilisé ce terme en
parlant de distance c'est ce qu' il
s'est cassé quelques chauffeurs cas
c'est peut-être le vin oui c'est il
s'est quand même cassé quelque chose
parce que dans des moments aussi grave
ait quelque chose de cassé cela dans un
moment si kraft vous avez un peu
l'impression que des partenaires
ressentent exactement les mêmes choses
moi j'ai eu des échanges avec jean
christophe cambadélis qui était un cas
très bien compris de quoi je parlais et
comprenait parfaitement et c'est vrai
que de la part de la part du
gouvernement
les premières attaques qu'on a eue de
monsieur cazeneuve et y compris manuel
valls était vraiment mal venu et je
pense que il faut à mon avis que chacun
regarde enfin réfléchissez un peu plus y
compris si on en voulait un peu moins
écologistes parce qu'à un moment ils ont
un discours de vérité y compris sur le
budget y compris sur la politique
gouvernementale
peut-être qu'il y aurait peu de
réactions aussi ferme sur six vins c'est
peut-être que il aurait le plus de
compassion plutôt propose de passer sur
un autre sujet c'est celui de la réforme
territoriale qui passait à l'épreuve du
sénat manuel valls est venu défendre de
mardi à la haute assemblée son projet de
13 régions qui a été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale le sénat lui en vo
on va regarder tout ça mais manuel valls
laisse quand même la porte ouverte
il est venu pour tenter de redonner sens
et cohérence à la réforme territoriale
c'est un grand oral tout vu plus
attendus
l'elysée avait 10 13 l'assemblée
nationale a répondu 12
le sénat lui propose une carte de france
à 15 régions
de quoi rendre le projet illisible c'est
la confusion c'est la confusion la plus
totale personne n'y comprend rien alors
manuel valls est expliquée devant le
nouveau sénat de droite
la tarification est l'objectif monsieur
le président retailleau clarté
efficacité baisse de la dépense publique
proximité manuel valls a aussi plaidé
pour un renforcement de tous les
territoires qui tienne compte des
spécificités locales
avant de donner ses préférences en
matière de nombre de régions
nous avons besoin de clarté et à mon
sens la carte voté à l'assemblée
nationale à ce mairie une intervention
de plus de 30 minutes
et au final pas grand chose selon le
rapporteur du texte mais je n'ai pas vu
dans son discours en tant que les caps a
ressenti une ligne directrice forte avec
une opposition claire de nos
collectivités territoriales avaient des
compétences claires attribués à chacune
de ceux des collectivités
le dernier mot reviendra en décembre aux
députés lors du vote définitif de la
réforme
voilà sûr qu'on première à chacun sa
carte a comme président moi je regrette
un peu parce que vous savez nous puis le
début on est plutôt partisan de cette
réforme
ce que nous avons toujours dit c'est
qu'il fallait pas s'arc-bouter sur un
chiffre 12 régions 13 régions case
région la question de savoir est ce que
quelle est la raison qui épousent mieux
le bassin de vie et je pense que là des
deux côtés soit l'assemblée ou au sénat
à chaque fois les quatre mois en tout
cas ne satisfont pas parce que poser les
choses franchement pour avoir une carte
des régions plus moderne il faudrait
permettre les départements des queues de
s'éclater dans plusieurs régions c'est
pour ça que nous avons défendu leur
adoption et il me semble ça c'est sûr la
trappe
c'est sur la tam et vous aviez vu qu'à
la fin la semaine nationale cet été ça a
été supprimée la le sénat en oeuvre mais
moi j'attends de voir mais surtout je
pense que il y aura une carte là il faut
aussi regarder comment évoluent ces
régions là et comment peut- être en 2020
on fait le point quant les conseils
généraux en tout cas une partie seront
closes
en 2020 c'est pas pour demain on va voir
ce que les français pensent de cette
réforme c'est notre zoom de la semaine
il nous a rejoint sur ce plateau
françois kraus bonjour 7 directeur
d'études à l'ifop et vous avez réalisé
une étude
alors à partir de la carte adopté la
carte de gamme en salle à 13 régions
quel est votre verdict il faut
comprendre que les français adhèrent
plus tôt au principe du projet de
réforme territoriale
c'est à dire la diminution du nombre de
régions à la disparition progressive des
départements et au renforcement des
pouvoirs des intercommunalités
en revanche ils sont majoritairement
opposés à la carte qui a été proposé par
le gouvernement autour de 54 % sachant
que leur position 13 régions
oui c'est ça oui parce que la la le
projet du sénat et en arrêtant un peu
plus récents on n'avait pas testé mais
on sait ce qui est intéressant c'est que
la position des français sur ces
questions elle est étroitement lié à
leur région de résidence savoir si la
région est ou non concerné par le rôle
et les régions qui sont pas touchés
comme l'ile-de-france où la paca sont
massivement favorables les régions qui
vont fusionner dans un ensemble
briseront un poids relativement limité
comme la picardie l'auvergne le
languedoc-roussillon eux sont plutôt
opposées proposé sur la carte mais
opposés sur la réforme enfin on
économise beaucoup 64 des français sont
favorables à la diminution est de
compenser sa région on y est on est
typiquement pour des régions comme
l'auvergne qui sont des petites régions
aujourd'hui la fusion c'est pas pour
faire des économies pour ces régionales
faut dire les choses franchement
fusionner le vin et ronald tu veux
simplement dire à louvain qui à l'heure
à des moyens beaucoup plus importants
pour faire des politiques locales parce
que c'est ça qui c'est ça l'intérêt d'y
donner plus de pouvoir social les
transports les routes
est ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
peut-être qu'au lieu de se bataillaient
de batailler sur la carte et sur des
pratiques assez politicienne il serait
plus intéressant d'expliquer aux
français
quel avantage pour vous d'avoir truqué
des collectivités plus fortes et un peu
plus renforcé il ya des régions comme la
picardie qui sont entre l'île de france
et nord pas de calais aujourd'hui qui en
fait sous
beaucoup d'être entre deux grosses
régions et avoir des pouvoirs plus
importants peut-être obligé aussi à ce
que les régions travaillent mieux
ensemble notamment sur la question des
transports peut permettre justement à
ces petites régions qui avaient moins de
moyens de bénéficier de sa et pour
l'auvergne se dire que la force de
frappe de rhône-alpes arrive sur les
lycées sur les transports sur
l'agriculture sur développement
économique peut aussi permettre d'avoir
une qualité de service si je peux parler
ainsi meilleur françois cros comprendre
que pour les français ils sont très
sceptiques sur le fait que y ait une
diminution d'une réduction veut dire la
paix du budget des dépenses réaliser des
économies à cause de ça et en plus ya
une certaine crainte du fait qu'ils
aient des idées des inégalités
territoriales qui vont entre les
territoires qui à mon sens qu'il ya des
craintes évidemment on en reparlera
parce que la loi sera votée au mois de
décembre et notamment sur les
compétences merci beaucoup france à
cause d' atteinte est revenue on va
passer au mercredi et le gouvernement
qui a mis fin au contrat avec la société
et comme ouvre alors il était remis en
cause ce contrat avec la société commune
depuis la fin de l'écotaxe ce
partenariat passé entre la société cette
société explication retour sur ce
dossier évidemment les commentaires de
chacun paul bouffard pauline dame
bureau 614 au sénat marie hélène des
esgaulx s'apprête à entrer dans l'arène
dans quelques minutes l'ancienne
présidente de la commission d'enquêté
comme move interpellera le gouvernement
sur la résiliation éventuelle du contrat
de l'écotaxe je veux éviter que le
gouvernement reste dans un flou que le
gouvernement essaie de s'en tirer avec
je dirais un tour de passe passe comme
il a fait un peu et bruxelles je veux
que devant nous il est vraiment la
franchise de son action me suivez demain
31 octobre c'est la date butoir le
contrat stipule que si l'état résilient
après cette date il devra 800 millions
d'euros immédiatement à la société com
ou en charge à l'origine de collecter la
taxe
les parlementaires veulent savoir alors
la question et direct je voudrais
revenir sur la saga de lego taxes
allez-vous vers une résiliation du
contrat par voie contractuelle d'ici
demain 31 octobre
parce que ses deux mains cette date
résulte du protocole que l'état a signé
cet été avec la société eco move
le gouvernement a décidé de résilier le
contrat de partenariat conclu avec
ecomouv le 20 octobre 2011 résiliation
pour l'état il y encore des zones
d'ombré sur la constitutionnalité du
contrat à la sortie la saga écotaxe est
relancé on avait un cadre aujourd'hui
pour le principe de pollueur-payeur
sur les routes de france ségolène royal
a pris la responsabilité d'arrêter
l'ensemble du dispositif c'est sa
responsabilité
ça coûte probablement plusieurs
milliards d'euros à la france des
risques totalement assumée par la
ministre de l'écologie et ça ça va être
discutée justement au regard du bien
fondé d'un certain nombre de dispositifs
de contrat initial au moins 800 millions
d'euros
non pas du tout ce n'est pas du tout
mais ce chiffre a été agitée depuis des
mois pour empêcher l'état de prendre ses
responsabilités
au même moment les salariés de la
société comme mauvais été reçue au
ministère de l'écologie par un simple
conseiller
ce soir les 210 employés restent dans
l'incertitude et ont des contacts et
comme vous fait à gashi je pense que
c'est plus un gâchis moi j'ai parlé de
scandale d'état et je maintiens mes mots
mais je pense que malheureusement cette
issue est liée à la décision unilatérale
prise par françois hollande et jean marc
ayrault en septembre 2013 tout
simplement
après l'action dé la prive le jour où
ils disent en suspens je n'étais pas
encore secrétaire national mais on a eu
de longues discussions à l'époque avec
pascal durand mon prédécesseur et puis
ronan dantec et les autres élus quittera
très engagée sur le sujet nous avons dit
sens et la mort de les quotas vous
rappeler pourquoi est-ce que ce projet
avait été suspendu il y avait eu des
manifestations très grave oui les
violences encore une fois excusez moi
pourquoi cette est suspendue parce que
en bretagne parce que l'industrie
agroalimentaire de mauvaise qualité
s'effondre on a eu des manifestations
très violentes en effet peut condamner
par ailleurs y compris soutenu par un
vice-président de l'assemblée nationale
quand même le rappeler et tout le monde
a pris peur sauf que l'écotaxe sujets
qui étaient là en 2009 françois fillon
en 2011 retard de la mise en oeuvre de
l'éco-taxe à cause des présidentielles
en 2012
ça aurait dû être le premier projet sur
la table comment se fait-il qu'en
allemagne on peut faire une éco taxe qui
rapporte 4 milliards d'euros par an
alors et qu'en france n'est pas
différent on n'est pas capable de faire
pourquoi pour deux raisons d'une part
parce que le dispositif qui a été
choisie en 2011 et c'est ce qu'a
expliqué à l'époque l'abstention des
écologistes notamment françois de rugy
qui suivait le dossier
c'était un parent
public privé qui pose beaucoup de
questions sur qui doit lever l'impôt est
ensuite et ensuite une fois que vous
avez donné un coup dans la bresse ont la
mention la suspension 2013 qu'est ce
qu'ils font les transporteurs routiers
qui n'en demandait pas tant il se disait
pas en continu et c'est ça le problème
est pourquoi je vais vous dire pourquoi
je suis extrêmement en colère là dessus
et je sais que on est beaucoup
d'écologie son partagent mon sentiment
comme nicolas hulot c'est qu'on a tué le
principe de pollueur payeur c'est pas le
problème et c'est ségolène royal encore
une fois oui mais elle a tort
elle a tort que regarder ce que fait
aujourd'hui le député savary député de
la gironde qui travaille sur les
autoroutes ça je me suis entretenu avec
lui il ya deux jours sur le sujet
qui paye aujourd'hui lente qui va payer
l'entretien des routes qui va payer
l'entretien des routes du gros tonnage
qui a été autorisé pour faire passer
l'écotaxe on a perdu deux transporteurs
routiers utiliser des calmes encore plus
lourd qui va payer
je veux dire c'est vous et moi avec nos
impôts
la méthode royal moi de savoir sur la
méthode royal aujourd'hui ou la
contester en tout cas sur les quotas que
je contexte depuis le début mai le sait
pas ce qu on en discute très souvent à
sa décision qu'elle était jalouse dalla
torre
je le dis tout simplement cesser c'est
pas qu'elle je suis désolé c'est elle et
avant jean marc ayrault est aussi
président de la république qui ont tué
les uns après les autres ce principe de
pollueur-payeur
et vous savez quoi une fois que vous
suspendez l'écotaxe évidemment que vous
allez utiliser les moyens juridiques
pour suspendre les relations avec
ecomouv tout le monde le sait et le
problème c'est qu'à la fin ça nous
coûtera à peu près de 2 milliards tous
confondus
c'est le chiffre qu'a annoncé par les
parlementaires aujourd'hui je parle de
ce qu'on doit et comme ouvre des
recettes qui ne sont pas prévus et qui
aurait annoncé les coûts des gens
engagés et qu'est ce qu'on fait de ses
salariés qui travaillent depuis deux ans
qu'on fait justement mais je ne sais pas
parce que la réalité surtout vous avez
remarqué les différentes initiatives
prises par le gouvernement pour essayer
de remplacer l'écotaxe la vignette que
pour certains transporteurs et il n'y a
pas d'autre solution vous allez morte
cette écotaxe où elle peut encore
ressuscité je pense qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement en tout cas a fait le choix
ne le reprenne pas vous demanderai pas
qu'elle puisse être mais moi je demande
qu'il y ait une écotaxe et je ne sais
pas simplement pour avoir des ressources
supplémentaires pour m
ag les infos sur ce transport s'est
surtout que quand on souhaite faire
évoluer la fiscalité il faut la faire
évoluer dans notre pays et notamment
appliquer un principe pollueur payeur il
faut l'écouter mais je vais vous dire
sur la fiscalité et c'est tout le
problème je pense depuis le début du
quinquennat
on a un gros problème sur le sujet c'est
qu'on fait du bricolage fiscal juste est
notamment jean marc ayrault avait lancé
cette grande réforme fiscale qui n'a pas
vu le jour
et vous voyez que son plein de sujets on
a du petit bricolage avait justement on
va parler de l'inde un sujet sur
l'écologie est aussi sur la question des
dividendes 7 au jeudi
voter est annulée dans la foulée exit la
taxation des dividendes pour toutes les
entreprises un amendement socialiste
avait été présenté mais face au tollé
suscité le gouvernement appelle retrait
de la mesure explications marc ela bhatt
l'amendement suscite la colère des
entrepreneurs et d'une partie des
responsables politiques adoptée en
catimini mardi soir dont le plfss 2015
le scrutin est ouvert
il prévoit notamment la fiscalisation
des dividendes versés aux sociétés
anonymes et aux sociétés par actions
simplifiée selon l'opposition c'est un
coup dur pour la liberté d'entreprendre
et la france elle a besoin que les gens
créent des entreprises qu'ils
investissent qui prennent de rites du
risque avec leur épargne avec leur
argent parce que c'est comme ça que
l'économie prospère si on leur dit vous
faites le mais vous serez taxé comme
tout le monde ils ont dit on va faire
comme tout le monde sont là ça vaut plus
le coup comprennent aucun risque et du
côté du gouvernement aussi l'amendement
déposé par les députés socialistes est
loin de faire l'unanimité
à partir du 1er janvier le conseil de la
simplification se dotera d'un comité
impact entreprises il contrôlera les
études d'impact des projets de textes et
vérifiera l'application de la règle zéro
charges supplémentaires créés pour les
entreprises il faut que nous y soyons
attentifs au gouvernement comme au
parlement
il ya d'ailleurs des petits exemples
c'est l'erreur qui montrent que la leçon
n'a pas encore été retenu mais nous
éveillons ce matin michel sapin a donc
demandé le retrait de cet amendement
pour gérard bapt rapporteur du texte à
l'assemblée nationale
l'état a subi des pressions il est bien
clair que auprès du gouvernement dû se
manifester non seulement la cgpme qui
l'a fait de manière très très violentes
mais aussi certaines embrasement
puisqu'un grand quotidienne a annoncé
que cette mesure poserait 1 milliards de
prélèvements supplémentaires le
gouvernement
maintenant va discuter au niveau du
sénat et puis le texte reviendra à
l'assemblée le député ps ne compte pas
en rester là
il espère bien retravaillé l'amendement
il le faire adopter au sénat lors de
l'examen du plfss le 5 novembre prochain
vous parlez de bricolage tout à l'heure
est ce que c'est le cas sur cette mesure
est ce que c'est un couac
non mais je parle de bricolage et je
maintiens le mot c'était déjà ça quand
on supprime une tranche d'imposition de
manière un peu un peu rapide
l'amendement il n'est pas inintéressant
il dit qu'il faut un peu taxé le
dividende et les revenus du capital
comme les revenus du travail et je pense
que les socialistes se retrouvent là
dessus mais bon j'aime l'entreprise
l'entreprise et pourrait penser que
l'entreprise peut aussi participer aux
finances du pays parce que l'entreprise
je crois gomis comme non je pense que
quand l'entreprise reçoit 40 milliards
de cic -qui notamment permet d'augmenter
les dividendes
voilà comme on l'a vu je pense que les
entreprises peuvent aussi être mises à
contribution sur leur participation aux
besoins du pays y compris on le voit est
encore eu là des annonces sur la
simplification qui sont quand même pas
anodine pour les entreprises et
l'ensemble du monde du travail mais qui
me semble quand même que il n'est pas du
tout aux scandales que ce député en fait
applique tout simplement le programme du
président de la république en tout cas
le programme présidentiel
monsieur selon vous mais je pense que je
voudrais c'est du bricolage donc en fait
on voit bien que victor allis et des
pigeons et mavericks qui m'occupe de
logement je regrette de ne pas avoir
créé les castors parce que je pense que
mes jolies très franchement parce que
finalement aujourd'hui c'est les lobbys
les plus forts et c'est toujours ça
accès lancé on est forts avec les forts
et on est l'effet qu'on les laisse se
taire mais c'est assez étonnant quand
même que michel sapin et on va dire
l'encens et christophe christian iv
quand même n'est pas aussi discuter plus
en a moins que son rapporteur et moi il
me semble qu'à voir une graduation dans
la dans la taxation sur des dividendes
n'est pas du tout scandaleux je ne
connais pas l'amendement dans sa
globalité sa mise en oeuvre
mais il faudrait aussi que les cris
d'orfraie posées par les entreprises à
un moment où l on 40 milliards dead
il faudrait quand même peut-être que
chacun retrouve un peu raison et
reconnaissent que jamais un président un
gouvernement en avait fait autant en
trois ans sur les entreprises y compris
le gouvernement précédent le fasse pas
le gouvernement fillon quand même vous
parlez des dividendes à parler d'argent
mais je veux savoir ce que vous avez
pensé de cette étude qui a été menée par
rené dosière sa célèbre député qui va à
la chasse un peu au gaspi plus 7,1 pour
cent d'augmentation pour les conseillers
ministériels a pas grand chose à voir
avec ce qu'on vient de dire mais c'est
important parce qu'il faut le signaler
cette semaine plus de 1700 1% de demain
sans passion non d'augmentation -
saint-roch pour les conseillers moi je
je quand jean marc ayrault a lancé son
premier gouvernement il avait il avait
réduit la taille des cabinets je pense
que ce n'était pas anodin mais ç'a eu un
effet de 15 personnes uniquement dans
les ministères
la réalité c'est quand vous faites ça
vous réduisez le poids du politique par
rapport aux administrations maj les vue
puisque j'ai quand même beaucoup
travaillé avec les ministres du logement
et donc j'ai du fait que je suis le
régional et que je suis en charge du
logement en ile de france
il faut pas non plus avoir une vision
totalement juste gestionnaire et
financière
il faut aussi dire que dans les
ministères pour que le travail soit fait
correctement et qu'il y était une bonne
chose il faudrait que je regarde en
détail son étude mai
que les ministères d'avoir quinze
conseillers en et vingt six et vingt
personnes qui travaillent et qui
travaille à fond sans soulever me semble
me semble correct mais après il faut pas
non plus qu'il y ait des abus et des
salaires ahurissants le problème c'est
dans les conseillers ministériels vous
avez des gens qui gardent leurs salaires
quand ils sont très haut car ils sont
issus de la fonction publique et ça va
les récupérer pour l'émetteur est
d'accord on va passer toujours au jeudi
s'ils voulaient bien à assembler
toujours la loi antiterroriste a été
adoptée à quasi unanimité mesure phare
la confiscation du passeport pour les
candidats au djihad
le texte passera au sénat la semaine
prochaine pour un dernier vote les
parlementaires écologistes avaient dit
que ce texte avait des relents
liberticide je reprends les mots
exaltant vous êtes toujours d'accord
avec ce terme mais est ce que vous
n'avez pas l'impression que c'est quand
même un texte rigoureusement
indispensable alors on d'ailleurs on ne
remet pas en cause un essai de ce texte
mais nous avons critiqué ce qui a été
proposé sur les libertés numériques et
nous ne sommes pas les seuls l'ensemble
du monde numérique critique cette vision
très administrative
alec y compris dans la discussion des
discussions à quasiment un aveu du
ministère de l'intérieur quand il
explique il regrette que le juge
administratif puisse pas intervenir
alors que je rappelle ses juges
judiciaires qui protègent les libertés
quand même dans ce pays et il ya eu un
contrôle très a priori sur les libertés
numériques et je pense que c'est un des
volets qui nous nous a inquiétés nous
l'avons dit après que l'état se saisisse
de mesures qui doivent être équitables
mais qui doivent être sérieuses sur la
question elle compose terrorisme c'est
nécessaire en même temps il faut
exactement puis en plus je pense que
c'est pas ça fait pas le tout de la
lutte contre le terrorisme
il faut aussi qu'aujourd'hui on
s'interroge pourquoi des jeunes pas
obligatoirement mars de la société un
moment s'engagent dans des voies
complètement folle qui nous paraissent
extrêmement éloignée de notre vie
française et est ce qu'est ce qui cloche
dans notre modèle éducatif au modèle
d'emploi et de formation pour que des
jeunes ce sont six à la marche pour
allez partir en syrie par exemple et son
intégration
ça vraiment l'intégration car beaucoup
sont français et sont intégrés d'être un
petit peu plus léger mais voilà c'est
quand même un domaine politique katia
avec le plus de l'hebdo qui va vous
faire découvrir une nouvelle série une
fiction politique son titre anarchie
rien ne va plus en france le pays est
embourbé dans une crise grave françois
hollande décide de quitter de renoncer à
l'euro pour revenir au franc point de
départ de cette série diffusée sur
france 4 le reste eh bien ce sera à vous
de l'écrire c'est une première simon
barbarie a vu le premier épisode pour
vous on passe le rire même si les
français arrivent à mettre en place une
nouvelle monnaie elle vaudra rien des
millions de gens vont perdre leurs
économies tomber dans la misère
face à ça nous la belgique sommes en
première ligne des belges qui viennent
en aide à des français en détresse c'est
le point de départ de la nouvelle
fiction politique et participative de la
chaîne france 4
anarchie la france a décidé de sortir de
l'euro et alors un pays en faillite
c'est la crise humanitaire assuré et
c'est notre boulot
l'humanitaire ou souvenez donc on
anticipe on transforme l'antenne en un
poste d'accueil de distribution de
vivres pour français en détresse inédit
expérimental et loufoque oui le premier
épisode diffusé jeudi dernier il dépeint
la france comme la priorité des
humanitaires suite à la faillite d'une
grande banque les français n'ont pas
plus de 40 euros par semaine pour vivre
abandon de la monnaie européenne retour
du franc et marine le pen qui appellent
à un gouvernement d'union nationale
bref c'est l'anarchie second france 4
les gens se battent pour quelques
milliers d'euros
on a même des dames attaque à la voiture
bélier dans quelque chose ça risque
d'état pénurie totale de cash
ensuite la pénurie nourriture et la
suite alors ce sera au public de
l'inventer car bien plus qu'une fiction
participative la chaîne insiste c'est
une expérience transmédia sur le site
internet anarchie point fr les
internautes peuvent proposer de nouveaux
personnages contribué à la suite du
scénario
un comité d'experts fera le tri dans
l'urgence car chaque épisode 8 au total
sera tourné en une semaine de faux
journaux télé et de faux articles seront
réalisés par des vrais journalistes afin
d'alimenter quotidiennement le site
internet
anarchie ou l'histoire d'une france qui
décroche à voir maintenant si le vrai
public lui accroche alors vous est-ce
que vous accrocher à ce type
d'initiative avec un ton un peu
catastrophique mais quand même une
fiction participer je trouve intéressant
encore plus que j'ai regardé
mais je peux être au bout hier soir ce
qui est assez intéressant c'est d'être
assez proche finalement de ce qu'on peut
entendre dans le discours politique
actuel et en même temps aussi un peu
éloigné j'aime bien cette idée de quand
même essayer de s'interroger sur ça
serait quoi population par exemple
et puis cette idée aussi d'être dans une
écriture audiovisuelle qui en lien avec
avait contribué juste eu le temps de
regarder mais je vais les voir quelle
était la place de leader écolo dans
cette idée qu'est ce qu'il raconte non
mais je trouve que c'est très
intéressant y compris quand on a quand
même distance avec la politique
aujourd'hui qui est réel qui s'exprime
dans le pays et je trouve ça pas mal
aussi que par le biais de la télévision
on puisse avoir et s'est trouvé un lien
avec des jeunes et des moins jeunes qui
écoutent la politique et ça fait ça peut
faire oui merci beaucoup emmanuel cau
musique à notre émission occasion son
retour la semaine prochaine
même lieu même heure très longue et de
bagram sur lcp public sénat et merci de
votre fidélité